ARE, CASTRATION.
MEDIEVAL MOMENTS CALL FOR
MEDIEVAL REMEDIES AND THIS IS
DEFINITELY A MEETING OF.
SO ETHAN, ARE YOU COMFORTABLE
WITH THIS AND ARE YOU
COMFORTABLE THAT ONCE YOU ARE
ACCUSED OF SOMETHING, YOU SHOULD
BE THE ONE TO DISPROVE THE
ACCUSATION AND IT'S UP TO YOU TO
PROVE WHAT YOU ARE SAYING ABOUT
YOU ISN'T TRUE.
>> I THINK WHAT WE HAVE TO HAVE
IS A HEARING OF BOTH SIDES, AND
I THINK WE WILL HAVE THAT FROM
DR. FORD.
AND THAT'S THE SUPPOSE IT
WITNESSES THAT HAVE OCCURRED.
IT'S NOT UP TO PROCESS, THIS IS
LIKE A JOB APPLICATION.
>> HOLD ON, LET ME BACK UP.
YOU ARE ARGUING SOMETHING
PARALLEL TO WHAT I ASK YOU.
I'M IN FAVOR OF ALL OF THAT, THE
QUESTION IS WHAT DO WE MAKE OF
YOUR PARTY LEADERS, MEMBERS OF
THE JUDICIARY PARTY SAYING, WE
HAVE AT LEAST THREE DEMOCRATIC
MEMBERS OF THE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE SAYING THAT IN PLAIN
INTRO, ENGLISH.
PROVE YOU ARE NOT GUILTY, ARE
YOU COMFORTABLE WITH THAT
STANDARD THAT'S AN UN-AMERICAN
STANDARD?
WE'VE NEVER SEEN IT BEFORE AND
IT'S HAPPENING NOW.
I WANT TO KNOW WHAT YOU THINK OF
IT.
>> I'M NOT COMFORTABLE WITH THE
SCENARIO, WHEN THEY SAY, PROVE
YOU ARE NOT GUILTY.
AND I'VE BEEN CONSISTENT ABOUT
THIS THROUGHOUT THE ENTIRE ME
TOO MOVEMENT.
WHEN THERE IS SINGLE ACCUSER
IT'S HARD FOR TO CALL FOR
SOMEBODY'S JOB TO BE LOST.
WHEN WE HAVE MULTIPLE ACCUSERS
COMING FORWARD, PLUS MICHAEL
AVENATTI IS TEASING ANOTHER ONE,
THEN WE HAVE A PATTERN AND WE
NEED TO LOOK VERY DEEPLY INTO
THIS.
>> Tucker: DOES IT OCCUR TO
YOU THAT WE HAVE A PATTERN OF
PEOPLE MAKING CHARGES THAT THEY
CAN'T SUBSTANTIATE TO ACHIEVE
POLITICAL ENDS?
IS THAT A POSSIBLE EXPLANATION
FOR THAT OR AM I A SEXIST FOR
SUGGESTING THAT?
>> WE HAVE TWO REALLY BIG
ISSUES.
ONE, I DON'T LIKE THAT POLITICS
IS THE BLOOD SPORT THAT IT IS
TODAY.
THE DEMOCRATS HAD ON THE LETTER,
BUT POLITICS IS POLITICS.
THEY SAT ON IT TO TRY TO DELAY
IT.
BUT WHAT'S HAPPENED NOW IS, WE
HAVE WOMEN WHO ARE BEING SLAMMED
AND SLANDERED, ATTACKED IN
DISBELIEF AND IN THE MIDDLE OF
THEM ME TOO MOVEMENT, IT'S TIME
TO GET THEM THEIR DUE.
>> Tucker: HOLD ON, IT'S NOT
ABOUT ALL MEN AND ALL WOMEN.
IT'S ABOUT BRETT KAVANAUGH AND
CHRISTINE FLORIDA.
THE CASE IS SPECIFIC.
WE ARE NOT PUTTING MEN ON TRIAL
OR TRYING TO EXONERATE WOMEN FOR
THE CRIMES COMMITTED BY OUR
ANCESTORS, WE ARE TALKING ABOUT
THOSE IN THE SENATE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE.
YOU ARE SUGGESTING THAT YOU ARE
NOT ALLOWED TO JUST BELIEVE
SOMEBODY BUT I RETAIN MY RIGHT
OF REASON AND, SHE'S CLAIMING
THAT THIS MAN SEXUALLY ASSAULTED
HER AND ALTER THE CLOSE OF HER
LIFE.
SHE CAN'T FLY IN AIRPLANES, SHE
CAN'T HAVE A RELATIONSHIP WITH
MEN.
SHE DIDN'T TELL ANYONE HIS NAME
FOR 36 YEARS DURING WHICH TIME
HE GOT MARRIED AND A CAREER.
DOESN'T SHE HAVE AN OBLIGATION
TO TELL SOMEONE TO STOP HIM FROM
DOING THAT IF HE IS IN FACT A
CRIMINAL?
WHERE IS HER OBLIGATION HERE?
>> EVERY PSYCHOLOGIST WILL TELL
YOU THERE ARE EIGHT PRIMARY
REASONS WHY A SEXUAL ASSAULT
VICTIM, A TRAUMA NOT COME
FORWARD.
>> Tucker: I'M NOT ASKING
ABOUT HER REASONS.
THE ODDS ARE 120 MILLION IN THE
FIRST PLACE.
IF HE'S ACTUALLY A CRIMINAL THEN
WE HAVE A RIGHT TO KNOW THAT AND
SHE HAS AN OBLIGATION TO TELL
US.
I KNOW IT'S HARD, BUT WHY
DOESN'T SHE HAVE THE RIGHT TO
KNOW?
IF BERNIE MADE OFF RIPS YOU OFF
AND YOU DON'T TELL HIS OTHER
INVESTORS, YOU ARE PART OF THE
PROBLEM, ARE YOU NOT?
>> DR. FORD DID COMMUNICATE WITH
HER THERAPIST.
>> BUT SHE DIDN'T NAME HIM FOR A
36 YEARS.
I'M SAYING IF IT IS TRUE, WHAT'S
GOING ON HERE?
DON'T THE REST OF THE US HAVE A
RIGHT TO PROTECT OURSELVES FROM
THIS DANGEROUS MAN, BRETT
KAVANAUGH?
>> HANG ON.
YOU HAVE A VERY POWERFUL PERSON
HERE, A JUDGE ON THE
NINTH CIRCUIT.
>> TUCKER, YOU WERE JUST TALKING
ABOUT THE PRIVILEGED ELITE AND
THE WEALTHY AND THOSE IN POWER.
THAT WAS BRETT KAVANAUGH FROM
DAY ONE.
HE WENT FROM AN ELITE SCHOOL,
THAT'S CALLING FOR SOMETHING IS
TO CHANGE.
>> Tucker: IT YOU ARE
INTENTIONALLY DODGING MY
QUESTION.
WHICH IS ABOUT THE
RESPONSIBILITY TO PROTECT THE
REST OF US.
I THINK IT'S NOT JUST ABOUT HER,
AND HER FEELINGS, YOUR
RESPONSIBILITY TO OTHERS AROUND
YOU AND A SOCIETY AT LARGE WHICH
WE ARE IGNORING A PURPOSE
BECAUSE WE ARE TERRIFIED TO SEE
WHAT'S TRUE.
LET ME ASK YOU REALLY QUICKLY
ABOUT THE CREEPY LAWYER.
ALL OF A SUDDEN, THIS GUY WHO
WAS THE LAWYER FOR STORMY
DANIELS JUMPS UP AND DOWN AND
MAKES A SPECTACLE FOR HIMSELF,
AND THE PRESS KIND OF ATTACKS
THAT AND MAKES A JOKE.
>> MICHAEL AVENATTI IS A BEAST.
>> THAT IS TRUE.
>> JON MEACHAM SAID HE MAY BE
THE SAVIOR OF THE REPUBLIC.
>> HE HAS A BIGGER CALLING HERE.
THE PRIESTHOOD OR WHATEVER, HE'S
OUT THERE SAVING THE COUNTRY.
>> I OWE MICHAEL AVENATTI ON
APOLOGY.
THE LAST FEW WEEKS I'VE SAID IT,
ENOUGH ALREADY.
I WAS WRONG, YOU HAVE A LOT TO
SAY.
THE DEMOCRATS COULD LEARN
SOMETHING FROM YOU.
>> Tucker: SO THEY ARE
PROMOTING HIM FROM THE VERY
START, AND THAT WAS FINE.
BUT THE PRESS IS NOW STARTING TO
FALL FOR ITS OWN JOKE.
TAKING CREEPY BORN LAWYER
SERIOUSLY, AND, IT'S NOT ABOUT
ONE SPECIFIC ALLEGATION, IT'S A
SERIES OF ALLEGATIONS.
THIS IS A PATTERN OF BEHAVIOR,
RACHEL, THAT TOOK PLACE ACROSS
MANY MONTHS AND MANY YEARS.
I BELIEVE THAT WHEN THESE
ALLEGATIONS ARE SURFACED WITHIN
THE NEXT 48 HOURS, THERE WILL BE
NO QUESTION THAT BRETT KAVANAUGH
DOES NOT FIT TO SIT ON THE U.S.
SUPREME COURT.
>> HE HASN'T PROVIDED THE
ALLEGATIONS NEEDLESS TO SAY.
THIS GUY IS A BUFFOON.
THE CONSEQUENCES ARE SERIOUS,
WHY LET THIS CHARLATAN INTRUDE
ON THE PROCESS?
WHY ARE THEY ALLOWING HIM TO
TAKE CENTER STAGE?
>> MICHAEL AVENATTI IS TAKING A
PAGE OUT OF TRUMP'S OWN
PLAYBOOK.
BUT HERE'S THE DIFFERENCE,
MICHAEL AVENATTI HAS BROUGHT THE
GOOD SINCE HE STARTED
REPRESENTING THIS CLIFFORD,
STORMY DANIELS.
BUT IN THIS SPECIFIC CASE, HE
SUGGESTING -- HE HAS NOTHING TO
DO WITH ANY OF THIS.
HE SAYING THAT BRETT KAVANAUGH
WAS PART OF A RATE RING.
HE'S NOT GOING TO GET SUED FOR
SLANDER, SO DO DEMOCRATS WANT TO
BE TIED TO SOMEONE THAT
RECKLESS?
>> I DON'T KNOW ANYTHING ABOUT
THE ALLEGATION OF A RATE RING,
BUT HE CLAIMS TO HAVE OUR VERY
WELL THAT IT OUT RELIABLE
ACCUSER.
AND I'M VERY INTERESTED
COMPANIES TEASING IT OUT OVER 48
HOURS, AND THAT TIME HASN'T
QUITE MADE IT OUT YET.
AGAIN, HE BROUGHT THE GOOD SINCE
HE STARTED REPRESENTING STORMY
DANIELS.
>> HE CERTAINLY MADE SOME MONEY
AS STORMY DANIELS IS GETTING
BEER BOTTLES THROWN IN STRIP